people who claim to have been abducted
or had Direct contact with aliens were
most likely just tripping balls on a
dose of the old Joe Rogan special
what is Matt taking
yeah yeah
right yeah Matt does confound this a
little bit
no they might just be mentally ill or
vexed by demons yeah I don't think it
has to be drugs or they're confused or
they just don't know they might have
thought that it was yeah they could be
gullible I see blinking weird things in
the sky all the time
and like oh
yeah listen I wake up in the middle of
night and I think that I'm being probed
by a little green men you know and but I
think oh it was probably just you know a
light Breeze or something or your child
yeah get out of my room buddy
[Laughter]